your two characters have a sex scene
meaning you as Tommy have to have sex
with the actress that he's hired or
pretend to have sex for his film and
he's hoping the the love see yes their
famous sex scene in the in the room that
is repurposed so bad and just ridiculous
romance really ridiculously so much yeah
yeah repurposed the footage and made an
additional sex scene both of them play
within the first 30 minutes of the film
again I can't criticise because that is
something I would do opportunity but
what's so weird is you're walking around
with this thing over your member yeah
while you're directing in character and
and then you're in the scene of course
with him and it's got to be very surreal
because he's simulating the worst sex
scene ever that's right his position
doesn't know how it works yeah yeah I've
never had sex before yeah if it's an
alien from another planet has come down
is trying to replicate human life all
right we we have a clip here and this is
the first day you Tommy is paying for
all of this himself he's hired everybody
he is didn't rent the cameras he bought
them see it as he thought two of them
two sets also for high-definition real
Hollywood movies yeah real fun okay no
Mickey Mouse stuff yeah and so he and
this is the first day where he sets the
tone let's take a look okay today on top
of mountain day today we take first
steps on a great journey after today
which one of ourselves will ever be same
display work if chemistry between
character makes sense human behavior
betrayal it applies to all of us it's in
ourselves you love someone
what is love you need to have spirit
hope be optimist but can you handle all
your human behavior
and behavior of others right right see
what I'm saying you don't want to be
good gonna be great okay I have one
announcement this is bathroom I spend
many dollars on this is for me only
director only okay you know it was like
a real bathroom with like doors and
everything right right there this real
movie set here real movie set you know
no Mickey Mouse stuff copy that
that speech is like about nothing yeah
that is now I think the fourth time I've
seen that speech and I don't know what
he's talking about same speech James
would give us every day this is on top
of mountain time it's my favorite it
sounds like a time zone
you